A bunch of pensioners
anyways,
it's nice to be here and thank you all for coming.
I guess there's lots of people out there.
Yeah,
there is.
It's very nice to be here.
Be the down south here in Texas and Arizona.
That's.
It's been really good.
Very welcoming,
very friendly.
Nice hot.
The
water is liquid.
We're not comfortable.
Alright,
so I'm going to talk to you.
I think you broke the rules tonight.
Maybe get to more.
I want to concentrate on to.
I'm going to concentrate first of all on rule 10 rules for cise
and I want to use that rule to develop,
I guess
as the centerpiece of a meditation on the world because we don't perceive the
world the way we think the proceeds the world.
It's a studied perception for a long time from a biological perspective and if
you studied phenomenon from a biological perspective and you have any sense,
you also studied them from a philosophical perspective.
Philosophical perspective is what enables you to develop the ideas that you've
tested if you're a scientist.
And so,
and I've learned all sorts of things about the way that we perceive the world
that I think are really useful.
They're reading,
they're really useful to know.
So I'm telling you a bunch of those things tonight because I think it'll help
you understand well how you,
what your life and why you're like that.
It's a terrible thing to understand,
of course,
but I want to aim at something else too.
I want to craft the discussion so that we can deeply investigate the answer to
the question,
what should you aim at?
Because you have to aim at something.
We're aiming creatures knots.
That's like rule number one of perception.
So I'm going to tell you the story first about a very famous psychology
experiment,
which you can see online.
It was an experiment done
by Harvard psychologist who was interested in perception.
He's interested in something called changed blindness.
And here's how they experiment with.
I'm sure many of you have seen it.
He videotape a group of six people,
three dressed in black and three dressed in white,
videotape them in front of an elevator,
which wasn't really relevant,
but I'm just setting the stage for you and the team dressed in black had a
basketball and the team dressed in white out of basketball,
and they were playing a game.
The game was throw past the basketball,
not a very sophisticated game and the black team would pass the basketball to
the to the teammates dressed in black and the white team with trip pass the
basketball to their teammates,
trusted white,
and they would mill around in front of the elevator and they filled the whole
frame.
They weren't distant.
They weren't tiny.
Little people know a half a football field away,
but they filled the whole frame so you could see their facial features and
everything and so your job,
you'd come into Dan Simons lab because the.
His name was Dan Simon.
You come into Dan Simons lab and he'd sit you down and you'd sit down and you
listen to him because that's what we do in a psychology lab.
That's where thinking about too.
I'm just like,
when you come into the theater,
you point forward and the arts,
the stage you do with the room tells you can do with the experimenter,
tells you.
That's part of establishing your aim.
He said to the his experimental,
participate participants watch the white team.
They're going to throw a basketball back and forth.
It's going to take about three minutes.
Oh yeah.
Africans count the number of times they throw the basketball and so you think I
can do that,
and you watch and you're watching the basketball.
You're counting very carefully.
You're concentrating on the task of him because you've been instructed to do
that and the video videotape runs until the end and dance as how many times did
the white team past the basketball and you'd say,
16.
Dan says your excellent right?
When you think you're pretty damn smart.
You went into a psychology lab that you participate in the experiment,
counter the basketballs properly.
It's like you're a credible human being.
No pointed,
and then Dan says,
what did you see?
Anything out of the ordinary?
And you say,
well,
no.
What do you mean?
He said,
what did you see the gorilla and you think,
what do you mean?
Did I?
Of course what gorilla?
Like if there was a gorilla gorilla,
I didn't see any damn gorilla,
and so Dan rewinds the tape and he says,
look,
don't count the damn basketball system.
He didn't say that.
He said,
don't do that.
Awesome.
Don't count the basketball this time.
Just watched the film.
So you watch it and sure enough like minute into the film,
this guy comes out.
It's not a real gorilla that's close enough.
He's like six foot four.
He's got a gorilla suit on.
It's the full thing and he stands right in the middle of the video and pounds
his chest for like five seconds and then Saundra's off about 50 percent of the
people who saw the video.
Sixty percent of the people didn't see the gorilla.
You think,
no,
I'd see the gorilla.
It's like,
no,
you wouldn't.
Not necessarily.
I'm a graduate student.
I showed that video to and then I showed it to him a year later he missed the
damn grill and the second time
really?
And so and so,
and you think,
no,
there's no way on that one.
It's like,
yes you are.
You're so blind.
You cannot in bloody will imagine.
It is absolute miracle that you just don't wash my face first in the walls all
the time.
Actually you do.
Life hurts because you do,
you don't see very well and you do walk face first into things all the time.
Maybe not literal walls,
but certainly metaphorical ones and that's often because you don't see what's in
front of you and it's because you're looking at the wrong thing.
And so what was so cool about that?
Experiments that insanely cool psychologists up to that point thought that while
we thought a lot of things and a lot,
not just psychologists on two,
we saw,
we thought it was easy to see the world that was kind of disproved back in the
early sixties when people were trying to build machines that can operate in the
world like people knew trying to solve the problem.
Machine perception.
You know,
we just thought,
well look,
there's objects right there.
It's pretty self evident.
You just see it.
Well,
you know how it easy it is.
All you have to do to see that object is look at it.
There it is.
It's not a problem.
It's.
There's nothing magical about it.
It's like,
yeah,
you turned to build a machine that did.
Does that you find out that perceiving separate law objects is so difficult that
it actually looks impossible.
It isn't obvious at all how we do it,
not in the least and that's why it's so difficult to to build machines.
That's why we don't have ambulatory robots.
Busing tables,
for example.
It's very hard to to see the world and so and then psychologists will even when
they figured out that it was hard to see world,
they still thought that you would perceive abnormals abnormalities in the world
that you would perceive the normally.
So if something strange happened,
you'd focus your attention on it right away.
It turns out that's not true.
No,
you can watch a video of six people throwing the basketball back and forth to
teams of three and a gorilla could come out right in the middle of that and you
will notice it.
It's like,
well,
what is going on there?
Why won't you notice that?
What?
Why?
Why did you see that and what did he answered?
One of the answers is because you were looking at something else and so then the
question arises.
It's like,
what are you missing when you're looking at what you think is important because
you come into the lounge and the psychologist says,
well,
the important thing to do here is to count the basketballs and you just fall
into that because while you're there to participate era,
cooperative personnel,
that you swallow the story immediately and what's so interesting about the fact
that you sold the story is that as soon as you swallow the story,
you listened to the experiment,
but you play out the game.
Then you immediately know adopting a particular cognitive perception,
not thought it's below thought.
It's actually what you see.
You adopt this particular sort of perception and then the world manifests itself
to you in one way and not another,
and it isn't necessarily the way that you would think and it makes this
question.
It's like,
what are you missing when you're aiming at what you're aiming at,
and that's what that is.
You might be missing almost everything.
That's what it looks like.
So Simon did another experiment.
This was even more amazing experiments.
He did this in Harvard Yard and there's lots of tourists in Harvard Yard.
It's a place where people go.
It's a very cool place actually.
And,
and there's undergraduate smelly all around him in Harvard Yard with the
tourists because it's a university.
And so what Simon did was he was wondering,
well,
just how blind people are,
how blind people.
They won't see a gorilla when it's right in front of them.
That's pretty blind.
Let's try another trigger.
So what he did was he sent out undergraduates to ask tourists for directions
with a map.
So imagine tourists to standing here.
Undergraduate is standing here,
undergraduate has map asks tourist where,
where,
where things are in the article.
Okay,
so person standing here versus down here.
Now some work.
We would come by two of them and they're carrying that door like this.
And they hear the door and they routinely walk right between the tourist and the
undergraduate,
walk right between them.
And then as the undergraduate is blocked from the tour view,
the undergraduate grabs,
the door,
keeps on walking,
and one of the people that was holding the door grabs it and starts talking to
the tourists.
So Dan figured out how to swap the person and about 60 percent of the people who
were giving you extra stuff.
The undergraduate didn't notice that they were talking to a different person.
It's like,
so what does that imply?
It implies that like you're out there in the world talking to people and they're
just shifting into different people right in front of you you don't even notice.
And then he did it in a like a convenience store.
And so he would have people come in and interact with the convenience store
owner and the convenience store owner were ducked down behind the counter to
grab something and then a different person would pop up.
Again.
More than half of the people didn't notice that it was a different person.
That was even if they were wearing different colored clothing and you think,
well,
what does this mean?
What does this,
It means that you don't see any more of the world.
Then you need to see in order to get what you're aiming at.
That's what it means.
It really,
really literally means that you actually don't see it.
It's not that you don't remember it.
It's not that you don't think about it.
It's that you're physically incapable of seeing,
and this experiment has been replicated in many,
many ways.
If I took you out of the room one by one out of the room that you're sitting in
and I said,
well,
what color was the floor?
Because can't tell right now because it's dark,
but it wasn't dark.
When you came in here,
you wouldn't remember what color the Flores and the reason for that is,
you actually don't care.
What do you care about with regards to a floor?
Well,
mostly you care that it doesn't move.
You don't want the floor to move.
That's a bad thing and so as long as it doesn't move,
you don't have to perceive it and that's sort of the rule.
And why don't you want the Florida move?
Well,
what does it signify if the floor moves?
Well probably signifies that maybe there's an earthquake and that's a bad thing.
That's a seriously bad thing.
I was in a hotel once and I was looking at.
This was a scientific convention.
I was looking at this.
It's kind of like an advertisement for a scientific paper.
They're called posters.
They're little advert there.
Advertisements for scientific papers and you put yours up on this like wall
board room divider.
Basically dependent upon people come by and ask questions about your experiment
and all of a sudden I fell over.
I was knocked off balance and the reason I was balances because the wall beside
me moved.
It was a big hotel and the wool move.
You do not expect that.
Do not expect that a move toward a bath.
Well,
it turned out that they have movable wall who knew?
Right.
But it was one of these dividable rooms and so.
But it took me off guard so badly that it just about knocked me over,
but normally I wouldn't even.
I was already at myself in the room.
Normally I wouldn't even.
I wouldn't even pay attention.
You don't pay attention to anything that doesn't get in your way.
Now that's an interesting thing.
That's an interesting thing because you see the question is what do you see when
you look at the world?
Right?
Okay,
now we're going to take this apart because it's unbelievably important this.
So
when you're watching the basketballs,
you use the central point of your vision to process the visual field.
Now you can.
You can kind of detect this yourself.
Like if I look at this gentleman in the front row and I looked at his eyes and I
can see his eyes and I can see his face in it,
quite high resolution,
but if I look at him and I pay attention to the people to assign from looking at
them,
what I notice is that the farther out of the center of my seal division,
those people become,
the less I can really see them.
Like I'm pointing at a woman,
I think here,
I can't tell because I'm looking at the guy right in front of me.
I think she's dressed in red,
but I can't see you there.
I know you're a human being,
but I can't see your face and you people over there basically just blurs and I
know that you're there,
but of course when I point I want to look because then I can see you,
but looking at you and you,
you guys are low resolution.
You're like simpsons characters except you're in the black and white and I can't
even tell that.
It's just so.
Even in the periphery of your vision,
things are black and white.
You can't tell that,
but that's the case and mostly over in the periphery you don't see things unless
they move.
You know how in Jurassic Park dinosaurs didn't see anything and listen,
well,
that's what your vision is like in the periphery because you don't have much
brain power over there.
In the periphery,
you can.
You're not that up and so the way that your brain is that essentially
compensates for your lack of visual Cortex is by only allowing you to see things
that move,
something moves in,
periphery Gloria towards it and look at it,
and then you think,
well,
I saw that all along.
It's he did.
You saw a brief flash of movement.
You actually use different parts of your brain process,
different parts of your visual field.
So anyways,
when you're.
When you're looking at the basketball,
I think,
okay,
what is it exactly?
What exactly is going on when you're looking at that basketball and that
experimenter?
Well first of all,
you're playing the role because the role is experiment,
experiment the subject and it's a little drama and the drama and the
experimenter to when the experimenter is basically the costs where you treat him
or her like a higher status private.
Your job is to listen to them and to take instructions and that's essentially to
a dog.
The story were the role that they tell you to play and you'll do that because
when you volunteered for the experiment,
you're already in for that experience.
Just exactly as I said,
just as all of you in some sense volunteered to come here and you do what the
route tells you.
The room is set up so that the seats face this way and so you come in here and
you obey the room.
You see this way and it was a focal point and the focal point is this stage and
then room implies that what's is going to take place on the stage and you're
here for that experience,
so you focus on me at the moment and hopefully the deal is that I tell you
things that are interesting because that's what the room is set up to allow to
happen and so all of that shapes your perceptions in a very,
very direct way.
And when you go into this lab and Dan tells you to sit down and count the
basketballs,
your experimental subject,
you're civilized human being.
You're obedient person.
You're a good sport.
He's the authority figure.
The context of the university is set up to sort of hammer that home.
You're not going to tell them to go to hell and when he asks you to watch the
basketball,
unless you're unbelievably antisocial,
you're not going to do that.
So it's a drama that you're undertaking and he offers you a value system.
And the value system is something like if you're a good person,
you follow instructions when the system is set up so that following instructions
is the civilized thing to do and to act out that stability.
You sit in that chair and I give you a set of stage instructions about how you
should act and then you act them out and you agree to do that.
And then that establishes your perceptual set and that determines what's
important in the world and that determines what manifests itself in the world.
And so then you count the basketballs even though,
why the hell are you counting basketballs?
There's no particular reason except we want to do a good job.
And because of that you miss what's vital.
So that's the extended version of the,
of the,
of the narrative.
So now if the griller would've jumped up and swipe the ball and you were
counting it,
you would have seen it.
If things get in your way that you see them.
So then let's figure out what you see.
So when I look at someone,
again personal in the front row,
I generally look at their face and we generally look at other people's spaces
when we talked to them.
And we're very good at facial recognition by the way.
You have specialized brain areas for,
for recognizing faces and faces,
broadcast emotion and intent and like your face is like a video screen important
which emotions play and you want to pay attention to someone's emotions and
motivational states and you can see them broadcast them on their face because
then you know what they're up to and you want to know what they're up to because
God only knows what they're up to and you want to make sure that what they're up
to is something that you would want them to be up to when you're around.
So you're watching their face and what you really want is their eyes.
And here's something really cool about human eyes.
So you know,
we have whites around our hooks,
right?
And the whites are white,
hence their name,
the whites of the eyes,
but like lots of the animals that were closely related to don't have lights like
that.
So gorillas don't for example,
but beings really do like our iris is really stand out against the white
background and there's a reason for that.
And the reason for that is what we really want to see when we look at someone
else's,
what the hell are they pointing their eyes out?
And so there's a famous social psychology experiment,
which is really a comical one where someone stands on the corner of a street,
just looks up like this and if you just,
you can do this,
you can be.
The scientist is go out on the street going the corner and just look up and soon
someone will come by and they'll look at you and you will look at them.
That's part of the trick.
You won't look at them and they'll say,
well,
I'm pretty important and that person is looking at me.
And so whatever.
What that means is that whatever they're looking at must be important,
more important than me,
and that must mean it's pretty important,
so I better look Joe,
so then someone will join you and look up as well,
and they were trying to figure out what you're looking at,
but then of course there's two of you looking out there and that's kind of
abnormal behavior on the street and so then the third person comes along and
there's two people standing on the street looking so you better know and so then
there's three p and you can soon you can get a crowd of people looking,
which is actually a good thing to do in a metaphysical sense.
This crowd of people.
So that's what we're doing tonight.
Crowd of people to look up.
That's really what we're doing tonight,
but that anyways.
Well,
you know,
the reason that you look at people's eyes is because you want to see what
they're looking at.
Because if you can see what they're looking at,
then you know what they think is important because it was looking at what they
think is important.
Because why else would you look at something if you didn't think it was
important?
So that's the thing.
You look at things that you think are important.
So that's very,
very interesting now.
And so the biological upshot of that is,
is that it's so important for human beings to see where other human beings are
appointing their eyes that all of our ancestors,
they didn't have sharply defined irises against the white background,
either got killed or didn't reproduce.
I get seriously important and so I contact is unbelievably important and our
visual systems are specialized so that we can detect tiny,
tiny deviations in someone else's glass like you would been know from across the
room.
When someone is looking at you,
you look at them,
you think you catch each other's eyes.
And,
and you know that,
that there's,
there's interest.
That's,
that's what I contact signifies.
And you know,
there've been SMRI studies.
So FM arise at technology that allows you to scan the brain as it's operating.
Then if you,
if you,
uh,
if you show men,
this is mostly been done with men,
but not only if you show men mentioned,
you show me a picture,
the same woman,
okay.
In one picture the woman is looking off to the left or to the right,
doesn't matter.
And in the other picture she's looking directly out.
So she's making eye contact,
at least in principle with the map.
If the woman,
this is generally an attractive woman in these experiments,
if the woman is making eye contact with Amanda,
then the gays will activate part of his brain.
It's associated with moving towards things,
right?
And so that's why I contact his pickup maneuver in a bar.
So because you latch onto someone,
you know and the timing has to be right,
but if you latch onto someone visually,
then that can be interpreted as a,
as interest in that can be interpreted as an invitation.
Well,
everyone knows that.
Maybe not.
Sometimes it's not an invitation.
Maybe you're just thinking that guy has the ugliest tie I've ever seen in my
life.
Right?
And then of course he comes over and talks to you,
that's just not good because you don't want to talk to someone with the ugliest
tie that you've ever seen.
So.
But in any case,
it's an invitation.
You can see the strange manifestations of that and all sorts of places you
wouldn't necessarily expect it.
So for example,
one of the things that has always fascinated me,
wow,
that's not true.
Some fascinates me from time to time I go into say into a drug store and you see
all the magazines in a raid there and what's the most common picture on the
cover of a magazine?
It's an attractive woman.
It's almost always doesn't matter.
It's a women's magazine or man's magazine and she's looking directly at you.
And the reason for that is that if a magazine has that image on the cover,
then people will go over to it,
approach it,
which is what you want.
If you're a magazine,
right?
We want people to approach you because then they pick you up and they buy you.
And so magazines evolve in some sense to have the maximally attractive figure on
the cover.
Because all the magazines that don't have that die and so that's why the
magazines ended up that way,
and so the part of the brain that is activated by that direct eye gaze is called
the nucleus accumbens and it's a brain area that is integrally involved in the
neuro neuro chemicals.
What it's part of the material substrate of the neurochemical system that uses
the neurochemical,
dopamine and dope mean mediates approach behavior,
but also importantly,
the open meeting is also the chemical that's who's released is facilitated by
drugs like cocaine or methamphetamine,
which are very,
very addictive.
And the thing that's so interesting about that is that those sorts of addictive
drugs make you feel like you're approaching worthwhile things.
That's why they're so addictive.
So if your life is meaningless and you take cocaine,
then it feels like you're imbued with a sense of purpose and that that can be
addictive.
And in fact,
that's the definition of addictive in some sense.
And so for a neuro chemical substance to be addictive,
it has to give you the sense that you're pursuing something of value.
And so then if you show people stimuli,
that's a phenomena that make them want to approach,
then you activate that part of the brain.
And so,
so now if if I'm watching someone and I can see what they're looking at,
and then I can look at it too,
then I know what they think is important and if I can infer what they're,
what they're,
what they think is important,
then I can embody who they are in my body and that's how I understand that.
So if I can see what you think is important because you're looking at it and I
can look at it,
then I can adopt that frame of reference and then I can read off my body what
you're feeling.
And that's how I feel what you feel.
That's how we understand each other.
So when you know this,
because look,
you go to a movie,
let's say what are you doing in a movie?
While you're watching the hero or the villain,
it doesn't matter.
You're watching a character and you see what the characters up to.
That's the plot.
Essentially.
You see what the character is up to.
And then you adopt that frame of reference and you sit there even though you're
sitting there and all of what's happening in that frame of reference is playing
out in your body and your emotions and your motivations and it's all happening
inside you like a simulation and so you get to live the curiously as a
consequence of adopting the frame of reference.
If the person that's in the fictional landscape and that's why you like fiction
because you can go and watch a fictional representation or you can read a novel.
It doesn't matter,
whatever the.
Wherever you can find a story and then you can pick up the reference frame of
the character in the story and then you can have the story.
You can sit there and learn everything there is to learn about that story just
by being passive and so smart because if the hero does something stupid and ends
up dead,
then you could think while I think if you adopt that frame of reference,
then you do something stupid and you end up debt and then if you're smart,
you don't do it because you'll end up dead.
Why bother with that?
Because you don't have to,
and so it's like thinking,
right?
Because here's a way of thinking about thinking.
Alfred North Whitehead said,
we think so that our thoughts can die instead of us,
which is so smart.
It's like when animals try to adapt to the world the way they do it because they
can't really think like weekend what an animal does to adapt to the world.
He's made a whole bunch more animals.
That's production,
right?
So the mosquito wants to adapt to the world.
It has like 10,000 mosquito offspring and they all definitely a little bit
randomly.
That's random variation and most of them aren't successful.
They just die.
But it doesn't matter because if you're a mosquito,
you only need to produce one mosquito in your lifetime to keep the whole
mosquito thing going.
And if it costs you 9,000,
999 dead mosquitoes,
it doesn't matter and it's better for the rest of us too.
So,
but so.
So for a mosquito's idea of an idea is to have a bunch of mosquitoes,
but your idea of an idea as to have a bunch of avatars of and to lay them out in
the fiction world until they had all the ones that don't do very well die and
then to imitate the ones that survive.
And that's part of the reason that we like stories because stories are part of
the way we think they're way we,
we there the way that we produce artificial variants of ourself,
you know,
hypothetical space so that the Darwinian process can occur in abstraction before
we embody it.
So it's super important and that's part of the reason that we really,
really,
really liked stories because stories are how we live and die without having to
live the dye.
So that's that set.
Without having to take the risks of real life and death.
We can choose what we're going to embody and we're doing that all the time and
we're sizing up.
Other people are seeing what they're looking at to see what their frames of
reference are,
to see if we should adopt them for our own too.
We want to know what they're up to and we see that people would admire and maybe
we adopt their frame of reference because that's pushing them ahead in the world
property and we see people we have contempt for and move away from their frame
of reference because that's not a good way to act in the world.
And then we tell stories to each other all the time trying to figure out what
frames of reference we should adopted,
which ones we should move away from it.
That's how we advance for roads.
It's very,
very sophisticated.
So okay,
so
back to back to how you frame the world.
So
let's say this will tell you about your emotions because it's good to know about
your emotional to what they are.
So let's say I'm over here and I want to walk.
I decided that I would rather be.
I'm like the chicken who's going to cross the road.
I decided that it's better on the other side of the road because that's why the
chicken crossed the road in case you in case you're wondering because everyone
wonders that,
right?
Why did the chicken cross the road?
Because the chicken thinks it's better on the other side of the road because
otherwise why would he want other options?
It's a grass is greener on the other side of the fence,
so it's a stupid window.
So you just stopped telling you.
So let's say I decide I'm going to walk to the other side of the stage,
so now this reality has transformed itself into a stage for me to undertake that
action and so now I'm looking at your all blurring.
Like I said,
like black and white simpsons characters.
I know you're there,
but I can ignore you because.
And that's one of you comes up and gets in my way.
Then I don't have to pay attention to the fact that you exist in order to do the
thing I'm going to do next and so I don't and I literally don't see you.
You're going just like the people outside.
The people out there in the city,
they exist,
but I can't see them because they're not hearing the way.
And so then I look across here and I think I evaluate the landscape and I mean
that technically as soon as I make a goal,
the landscape changes into a place of value.
And so.
And what are the values?
Well,
the values first of all are what's your relevance
in
the world?
It's unbelievable.
It's just
not the most important thing.
I should act like it's just too complicated.
So that's mostly what you do.
You just ignore every.
You just ignore absolutely everything except this tiny fraction of the world
that you need to pay attention to in order to get to where you're going.
And so that's another thing.
You don't really see
it,
but not really.
What you see when you look at the world is a map of how to get from place a to
place b and place b is better than placing because point eight,
let's say point B is better than a because,
well,
while it isn't why we wouldn't get it.
So not only do you see the point,
you're going to point b,
you contrast that with point a and you make the presupposition that what you're
aiming at is better than what we have.
In fact,
that's actually the definition of better in some sense,
right?
Better is what you're aiming at because while,
unless there's something gone seriously wrong,
sometimes that happens,
but we're not going to talk about that under normal circumstances.
The mere fact that you're intending to do something means that you value and so
it's a definition of value.
So anyways,
I'm deciding that I want to get to the other side of the steak and so now I look
at the stage and this is all irrelevant and this is all irrelevant and the floor
is Kinda gray enough,
doesn't matter.
It could be replaced with whatever color,
whatever resolution.
It's irrelevant as long as it doesn't move.
And I'm really irritated by that little chair,
a little stool in the middle because it's in my way and things are in your way.
Maybe you feel negative emotion.
So obstacles make you feel negative.
Emotion and clear pathways.
They make you feel positive emotions and that's part of the mapping function,
so one of the things that I've become known for,
let's say is this weird
shape that you should clean your room,
but you know it's not a cliche and here's why
you think that your room is room,
but it's not your room is there is the room,
the independent material room and that and that's.
That's not the relevant irrelevant room is the room that you inhabit.
It's part of your conceptual system and your value system.
If you spend two hours a day in a room,
we'd give them room and that room isn't the room.
That room is you for two hours a day.
It's an extension of you.
And if the room is health,
well that's you.
That's not helpful.
So you think,
well,
you have a room that's maybe not a good thing.
What?
Maybe it's not very fancy,
but there it is right in front of you and you can sort it out and set it up.
You can.
You can make it function as part of what you value,
which is what it means to clean it up.
And it's like,
what are you doing in that room?
It's a place to wake up.
It's a place to go to sleep.
It's a place to get ready for the day.
What are you going to do during the day?
We're going to get dressed or what are you going to wear and why are you going
to wear and how are you going to take care of it?
And it's a costume for you,
a dramatic costume to go out into the world in and to manifest your role.
You want to get up and have to sort through of horrible heat of disorder before
you can do whatever use was thing you're planning to inflict on the world.
That's a hell of a way to start your day.
It's like it's not obvious that you're ab up.
It's not right that you stop that.
You've got your rope construed property and just like what sort of person do you
want to be exactly on.
Maybe you set the room up as the stage on which the person that you want to be
can enter the world.
That isn't.
If you do,
if you have any sense,
and so to clean up your room is,
is all that,
it's to set the stage for the person that you want to be,
is to set the stage for the value structure that you're going to bring him to me
and it's going to how the world manifests itself to you.
That's the thing.
Your values structure determines how the world manifests itself to you and
that's actually the case.
It's not just metaphorical.
Now you know there's limits to that.
You can fail.
You going across the street and step up carelessly.
You can get wiped out by a semi trailer and you know there's a certain arbitrary
this to the world and the mere fact that you're laying a value structure on it
doesn't transform its nature entirely,
but it transformative nature a lot,
a lot more than you think.
So anyways,
we go back to my desire to walk across the stake and so I'm not happy that that
obstacle is in my way.
And so you can imagine that this might be my bedroom and it's just littered with
mes.
And so when I look at that,
all I see is a maze of confusion impeding me in the smallest of tasks and that
will make my heart sink,
will make me anxious and disgusted and angry and unmotivated,
especially if it's something that I've created around myself.
It's not helpful so that even the smallest steps that I want to take forward are
complicated by unnecessary obstacles.
You've got to asked her.
So I had a client once,
so interesting.
He had this dream,
he had a new chart.
He was 30 something he'd never grown up and he knew and he had this child and he
thought,
Jeez,
I better get my act together because,
you know,
before it was just me.
But now I've got this baby and probably I shouldn't be an immature more on
anymore because we're probably going to be good for the baby.
And so then he had this dream that I lightening bolt came into his bedroom,
his bedroom,
all lightning.
It was bombed.
And so he told me the dream and I said,
well,
you know,
you just had this baby and the baby is a potential,
is absolutely potential for,
for,
for good and for evil,
for the whole span of human ability.
Now you have this responsibility.
That's what the dream is showing.
This is incredibly charged things enter your life and it can bounce around and
do all sorts of damage.
You better straighten yourself up so that you can have them as property.
So we decided that he would start by cleaning his room was a mess.
Complete mess.
It's like he's 30 something and getting it clean his room.
It's like,
how pathetic is that?
What is it?
Inability.
You don't know how to do it.
Well,
that's pathetic.
And if it isn't inability,
it's like,
well you not willing to.
Well that's pathetic too.
So either way it's pathetic.
Or maybe you're too bitter about the structure.
Braille and clean your room.
And that's like your,
your protest all show God and reality.
What I think I'll just leave this room a maintenance room,
a catastrophe,
be my protests.
Yeah.
Do People Laugh about that?
But that's the,
that's one of the truth than in just not knowing how to do it or being lazy or
any of that as a form of vengeance to form a vengeance against reality.
So,
so we made a plan to clean his room and one of the things he thought he would do
is vacuum,
which wasn't a genius level hypothesis.
And so he came back a week later,
you said,
I tried to get back to my room,
but you know,
what happened?
He said,
I put the vacuum in the doorway of my bedroom.
So matching.
It was one of those push back humans,
you know,
so the head of it was laying against one side of the door Jamb and then the
handwritten was leaning against the other men.
He said for a whole week I walked over that vacuum to get into my room and I
thought,
that's a microcosm of your life.
I'm dead serious about that.
You can interpret that just like a dream.
It was absolutely a microcosm with his life.
Was like,
well,
why can't I get anywhere?
Well,
there's these damn they're obstacles everywhere.
The look was a vacuum cleaner right in my door.
How can I do anything?
You're in my door.
It's like,
well,
you put it there.
It sounded like he didn't notice.
He wasn't stupid.
He noticed he did it and we have a discussion about that.
It's like,
well,
why is your life so difficult?
Because he put up obstacles in your path.
All you just do not,
but you could just walk there and no.
Put it back in cleaner in front and then you think,
Oh God,
that's so much trouble.
Just go like,
I don't know.
What do I do?
I do play a video game.
I won't go to where I'm going because of all these damn dogs.
So what are the things you might ask yourself like you had to ask himself is how
many of the obstacles that get in your way that make you bitter?
It makes your world.
God only knows the answer to that and maybe here's something else that's even a
deeper question is maybe you put those obstacles there on purpose just so that
you have a reason so that you can be useless,
which is exactly what he was doing.
And he knew that he,
he came in and told me that he did,
that.
He was kind of laughing.
It wasn't that funny because he did it actually unbelievably screamingly
hilarious to tell you the truth was so absurd,
but,
but there was a terrible tragic element to the tube because he basically just
revealed to me and himself the whole essence of his life.
It's like,
so back to this,
back to the stool here.
Okay.
So you know,
one of the things I can do to decrease the negative consequences of having that
stool in front of me is just go like this.
That'd be nice.
I could just circumvent the obstacle attire.
So anyways,
if I lay out this landscape so that there are clear pathways to my goals and
when I looked at them landscape,
I'm happy.
And the reason I'm happy is because this is the definition of happy.
So here's how it is that you're happy when you are,
you have a goal,
it's a good goal
and things are set up so that you can move towards it.
And so then you think,
well that's very interesting because,
well,
first of all,
need goal two means you need a value structure.
And second it means that maybe there's a hierarchy of goals,
right?
Because some goals might be like the chickens goal just to get across the road,
but maybe there are higher order goals.
You might say,
well,
if you need a goal to orient yourself properly in the world,
what's the basketball to aim at?
Because if you're going to orient yourself to the world,
you've got a problem with having a goal and maybe you should have a basketball
because why not?
Why?
Why settle for something second rate and so and then the next thing is once
you've established the goal,
the goal that is good,
then why not clean up the pathways to it so that you have the road in front of
you so that you can walk towards your noble goal and then maybe maybe not
allowed some positive meaning to your life and there's no maybe about it.
That is exactly how it works.
And so one of the things you might ask yourself is it really there isn't any
positive meaning in your life.
Maybe you're aiming at the wrong thing.
And I tell you that you can think about that for about 15 years.
Like every day for eight hours you can take,
maybe I'm even at the wrong thing.
Maybe my life isn't playing itself out the way it should because I'm aiming at
the wrong thing.
It's like,
where's my error?
What should I be aiming at?
Well,
these are very good questions.
Very good questions.
Indeed.
They're the ultimate questions.
In fact,
what should you be aiming at?
There's a scene in Pinocchio to the movie I quite like.
Um,
so it's a,
it's a work of genius,
of course,
anatomy,
the work of Jesus.
It took people a long time to make that move.
They had to draw a lot of drugs and they were very high quality automators and
they have the sequence,
all those drawings and they had to come to a collective decision about what they
were going to draw and it had to decide to let the plot.
Every single bit of that movie,
every single tiny bit was the consequence of deep thought and collected and done
by a team of visionary genius.
And so it's worth thinking about,
you know,
even though it's for kids,
let's say,
um,
there's a great scene in there where Japan,
Oh,
makes Pinocchio would,
wouldn't edit puppet marionette.
So someone else's pulling his strings,
right?
Someone else is deciding what his values are going to be.
That's the Marionette.
He's not an autonomous being.
And Japan who's a great craftsmen and the positive father and someone who cares
for his child decides that it would be better if he was an antonymous and
complete being.
That's his wish.
That's a good wish.
If you're a father,
what the hell else are you going to wish for?
You want your son to remain a Marionette?
Is that the idea so that you can pull the strings are so that something else can
or do you want the strings to disappear and have the thing that's not fully
formed yet taken place in the world and Japan is a good,
is an archetype of the good father,
um,
as a,
as a craftsman and as a craftsman who cares about children and makes toys and
hasn't warmed Harlem as a safe place to be a place where kids can play and he
wants his child to expand completely into the world.
And so what he does is,
what does he do?
He wishes upon a star.
You think,
well,
you know,
we do that.
Maybe do that with your kids.
You tell them that you could wish on a star,
you wish on a falling star and everyone kind of knows what that means,
but not really.
You think,
well,
what does it mean to wish on a star?
And you think,
well,
what's The star?
Exactly?
And I don't mean materialistically speaking,
I know it is damn this point.
There's the star.
That's the material launching and there's the star.
That's the element of perception.
The same thing,
even though they're related upon one another star as a Hollywood star,
why is a Hollywood star a star?
No one ever asks that really well.
Star is something that you look up to star as something to emulate.
That's Hollywood star.
That's why people.
That's why people are star struck.
It's because in these people who are stars play these larger than life rules on
the screen and those are ritual models for emulation.
So a scar is something that you look up to so that you can emulate it,
and Japan all looks up to the stars and that also means that he lifts his eyes
above the mundane landscape,
right?
He's not trying to get from this side of the stage to that side of the stage.
He's thinking,
what's the highest possible thing I could aim at?
An answer that is the light that glistens in the darkness.
I can lift my eyes up to that and I can orient myself towards that.
The highest possible good,
and that's the wish,
and here's the upshot of that.
If you aim,
that determines how you perceive the world,
then the highest possible aim that you can aim at lays out the best possible
world that you can live in,
and that's actually the truth.
It's the hard core,
solid scientific truth that that's the case and so what happens with Japan knows
because he's a good man and he's put in the thousands of hours of discipline
necessary to be a careful disciplined crossman because he actually loves his son
and wants the best for him.
He looks up as high as he can possibly look and makes his wish and his wishes.
I wish that my son could be real.
It could be a real boy,
wouldn't headed puppet whose strings are being pulled by fate,
by forces behind the scenes,
and that's what that see me and it's absolutely.
It's absolutely brilliant and it catalyzes a kind of development,
right?
Because what happens is Japan makes his wish and then he falls asleep and then
the blue fairy shows up.
That's mother nature.
Mother Nature shows up and confers upon Japan.
No,
a gift,
and that's the gift of the beginning of autonomy and what that means is this,
if you're a good father and you have a son with you,
have a daughter for that matter and you wish above all that they will become
real.
The nature will step in and give them a hand and that's exactly how it works.
Right,
and then the child,
the child himself or herself has to undertake their adventure in the world.
They have to make their own moral decisions.
You're not.
You're not the owner of your child,
even though you might be their guide,
you might be the person who sets up the structure within which they can flourish
or not.
The child has to play his or her role and that's also brilliantly detailed in
the movie to deal with temptation seemed to decide whether to tell the truth or
to lie and all and to decide to be neurotic and to be a victim because of course
that's part of the Pinocchio Story.
He's a tracker.
He's tempted by criminals into v into adopting the stance of a victim.
So that's.
That's something we can all meditate on for a certain amount of time,
so you want to aim as high as you possibly can,
and then the right thing to appear to you in the world as obstacles and the
right things appear to you in the world as pathways to move forward and those
pathways to move forward towards the highest goal.
Fill your soul with a kind of contentment that allows you to withstand the
suffering that characterized as being without becoming bitter.
It's important.
It keeps you away from Hell.
It helps you orient yourself towards the highest possible
and then the world plays itself out in the proper manner.
Qualify suffering.
Things aren't good for me.
If life is unbearable,
then maybe I'm not aiming in the right place and that's something that's
endlessly we're thinking about and I think that it's correct,
so then you might think,
well have accepted that as a potential reality.
How can you characterize what it is that you might a map and so
and this I think is the answer in some sense to this postmodern conundrum that
we've been faced with,
which is partly a puzzle that's emerged as we've figured out that the world is a
very difficult place to interpret.
The world is very complicated.
There are many maybe ways to interpret it.
How do you know which of those?
How can you rank order those weights?
The postmodern claim,
and this is what's being taught in the universities.
I would say the postmodern claim is there's no way of ranking rank ordering the
multitude of ways that you can interpret the world.
You can't make a final decision about route a or route b.
it's a chaotic tumbled of unconstrained possibility and it's demolished say
literary criticism because for a long time people would try to understand what
the book men but the postmodernist so well.
The book means an infinite number of things and there's no way that you can rank
order your interpretations because of that infinite complexity and there's a
manner in which that's true because the world is very complicated.
Any given text is complicated,
how many ways can you interpret the Bible and endless number of ways because
it's such a complicated text.
It's tied into everything.
Depends on where you look.
It depends on how you look because of course how things manifest themselves to
you.
It depends on how you look and so it's a powerful critique except for one thing.
There is a very large number of ways looking at the world,
but there aren't a very large number of ways,
a viable ways of looking at the world.
That's a whole different story.
You know that because if you look at the edge of a cliff,
like it's a solid place to walk and you act that out and you end up a crumpled
pile of bleeding bones at the bottom of the cliff and that seems to be evidence
that that particular interpretation of that particular phenomena wasn't in your
best interests.
And so there's a very limited number of ways of looking at the world that you
might say are in your best interest.
And so that takes that terrible complexity that the postmodernist some sort of
put in front of us.
And organizes it and you can think this through,
and this is part of the way that you think through what it is that you should.
Amen and so,
and this is the evolution of morality as far as I'm concerned and I think that's
the right way to think about it.
Think about it metaphysically or theologically or biblically,
ear or ethically,
all those ways,
but it's easier in some sense and it's easier and and more in keeping with the
full body of our knowledge to think about it as something that's emerged from
the bottom up.
It's like,
here's the constraints.
Why not just do what's impulsively pleasurable?
I talk about that in rule seven.
Do what is meaningful,
not once speed.
Speeding is momentary pleasure.
It's cocaine is expedient,
right?
Promiscuity is expedient.
Gluttony is expedient of violence,
can be expedient,
victory can be expedient,
and something that works now and you might think,
well,
why not just do what works now?
And that's who that is,
because you're not just here now.
You're here now and you're here now and you're here now and there.
You are repeating away during time.
Right?
So there's the you that's sitting here now,
but there's the you that's gonna wake up tomorrow and there's the you that's
going to wake up in a month and in the year God willing five years in 10 years
and 20 years and so you can just take care of who you are now,
right this second in the most expedient possible way because the you that you're
going to me has to put up with the consequences of the you that you are now.
There's a funny scene in a simpsons cartoon.
So I think it's extraordinarily funny where homer is mixing up a quart of
oil
and a mark says,
well that's,
that's,
you should think twice about doing that in.
Homer says,
well that's a problem for future homework.
I'm sure.
Glad I'm not that guy.
So anyways,
I think that's very funny,
but that's exactly it.
Like you're all future homer's man.
And so
a little bit of impulsive expediency goes a very long way.
And so you have to think about your life as it iterating gay rights.
You have to play the game right now.
You have completed the right there.
On the way that doesn't compromise the way you play it tomorrow and it doesn't
compromise the way you play it next week,
next month,
next year,
and five years from now,
10 years from now,
and maybe the constraint is even more severe than that.
Maybe you want to play the game right now so that the game you played,
Mauro is slightly better in the game he played two years from now is even better
than that,
so you don't want to just play a game that you can repeat without.
You don't want to play a game that you can repeat at a plateau and you don't
want to play a game that you can repeat that deteriorates.
That's definitely a bad game.
Things are going from bad to worse.
Who wants to play that?
Well,
maybe if you're a marketer you can do that and you'll meet people like that,
but maybe one play a game that was like this one that's oriented towards
whatever that star is and so that's a tight constraint man and everybody knows
that that's the straight and narrow.
That's a tough one and then it's worse than that because it isn't just used it
at stake here and the iterated future use.
You're also embedded in the world.
It's like,
well there's you,
but then there's the person you're with,
your intimate partner,
maybe your father,
your mother,
your siblings or your children and they're just as much you as you are.
Maybe even more.
You know,
people will die for their children,
so maybe they're more of their children than they are themselves now.
You look at it so you have to propagate itself through time in a matter of
seconds,
but at the same time makes your children's life parents,
your siblings,
friends.
Same problem.
And then there's the broader community and so you actually have to organize all
your aims and stack them all up so that at the same time,
and there's not an infinite number of ways of doing that is a finite number of
ways of doing that.
And the final way is the way that you do things when you do them right.
And everyone knows that.
And that seems to be aligned with something like with something like telling the
truth or just rule eight in my book,
tell the truth,
or at least don't lie.